[Music]
I've never seen a time where all the
threats or so many of the threats are
all elevated all at exactly the same
time so blinking red lights analogy
about 911 all the lights were blinking
red before 911 apparently obviously all
of us missed it would you say that
there's multiple blinking red lights out
there I see blinking lights everywhere I
turn an ominous warning from FBI
director Christopher Ray on the threat
of a terrorist attack on us soil this
holiday season as a senior Hamas
official is now calling for violence
against American and British interests
across the world as retaliation for
supporting Israel's war against Hamas in
Gaza this amidst a surge of foreigners
flooding the US Southern border 10,000
people in a single day just this week
some on the US terrorist watch list
Customs and Border Protection sources
telling Fox News over 5 35,000 migrants
have already been apprehended for this
fiscal year with an additional 60,000
plus listed as gotway and again the
fiscal year began in November as we
first reported exclusively on Friday on
mornings with Maria on Fox Business
Customs and Border Patrol agents are
being warned to be extra vigilant after
the Mexican military seized 10
improvised explosive devices or IEDs at
the border as well as an armed
individual carrying an AK-47 among other
weapons in the Tucson sector during a
cartel gunfight on the Mexican side of
the Border joining me right now in a
Sunday morning Futures exclusive is the
chairman of the house Homeland Security
committee Tennessee Congressman Mark
green Mr chairman thanks very much for
being here this morning should we be
worried about a terrorist attack on us
soil absolutely we should be worried I
had director Ray in front of my
committee for our worldwide threats
briefing and he clearly said you know
that the open border has created both an
increased risk risk for his agents who
are now hunting these individuals inside
the United States and certainly an
increased risk to the American people
and he's honestly he expressed a real
fear and worry about what what's
happening in inside our country 294
terrorist watch list folks since this
president came to office compare that to
only 11 during the entire Trump
Administration well that's incredible
what are you doing about it so what
we're doing is an investigation into my
and and and what's happening at the
border the increased risk to Americans
getting that to the colleagues that I
have that we've got to convince to to
actually get rid of mayorcas he's he's
derel in his duty he's broken the laws
of the United States that have passed
Congress he's lied to Congress this guy
needs to go and I've got to convince
eight Republicans I think we can do that
that's what we're working on right now
well that's what I want to talk to you
about because margorie Taylor green came
out with her bill to come to the floor
to ensure that you had the process in
place to impeach Alejandra mayorcas and
eight Republicans voted against that
partly on process they wanted you to
bring the bill to the floor will you do
it yeah absolutely we're going to have
about three or four hearings in January
and then we're going to mark up the
impeachment articles that have been
written there are probably about four or
five different members who've brought
impeachment articles really rushing the
thing to the floor without a due process
and that's why I think many of those
eight voted no and I've spoken to all
eight most of them just want a a due
process you know to happen and we've
been doing that now for several months
that investigation wraps up this month
and then we will'll do a proceeding in
January okay so we're expecting you to
move to impeach Alejandra orcus in
January then well the Democrats actually
referred it themselves back when
Marjorie brought that motion to the
floor the Democrats themselves actually
referred it back to our committee so it
gives our committee the authority to do
just that let's talk about some of the
deportations or lack of deportations
what can you tell us in terms of ice and
whether or not the uh the department is
being honest when they say the border is
secure well they're definitely not being
honest about a secure border but I think
if you drill into I mean clearly the
border is wide open and no one even
Democrats you listen to Eric Adams and
all those talk about the crisis that's
causing in New York City and the the
Democrat Governor of Massachusetts who's
talking about a crisis but the real
issue here I think what really shows
intent on mayus is the fall in removals
i i in 2019 ice removed 267,000 people
in 2021 the first year of this President
it was
59,000 I mean that's like a 5x decrease
in deportations meanwhile Millions more
have come into the country I mean it
shows their intent is basically to
fundamentally change the population of
the United States and I believe to
empower the Democrat Party into
perpetuity that's their intent I think
that's a you know a misunderstanding of
where Latinos are voting these days but
that has to be their intent and they've
put the American people at risk
terrorist attacks fenel uh drug cartels
you mentioned the IEDs I mean this is a
huge risk to the American people they're
willing to accept in order to change the
electorate well is there no sense of
urgency whatsoever look what you're
telling us right now live yes we should
be worried about a terrorist attack on
us soil yes we've got wouldbe terrorists
coming through the Border yes we've got
drugs and human trafficking happening in
plain sight and what where's the urgency
here so we've already passed a bill
Maria back seven eight months ago that
would fix all of this and the Democrat
Senate is sitting on their backside
doing nothing I would love to see uh uh
them come to an agreement that actually
puts border security policy on the
supplemental but we're not going to put
more money into their hands I'll give
you an example we gave them $ 1.9
billion more dollars to do searches at
the Crossing sites they're only
searching 2% of Civilian vehicles and
177% of commercial vehicles it is absurd
to think that if we hand Joe Biden more
billions of dollars he's going to
actually do more border security so what
we're doing is trying to convince the
Senate to actually pass a bill that will
work which we by the way passed 6 months
ago well I mean also absurd is all these
meetings that Joe Biden has with XI
jingping as XI jingping undermines
America I've got to get your take on all
of these Chinese Nationals coming into
America through the wide open border
because we're looking at the pictures Mr
chairman they look like Engineers they
look like military AED men they're
wearing collared shirts they're coming
through the Border they certainly do not
appear to be people escaping from
persecution so what can you tell us
about this 1,000% increase in the number
of Chinese Nationals getting apprehended
at the southern border sure Maria I mean
think about it this way the most we've
ever had before was 1,800 in a year and
then this last year it's been 24,000 and
these are military AED folks you have to
consider that this is somehow a
strategic plan of the Chinese Communist
party you can't buy a plane ticket if
your social credit score doesn't
accomplish certain level in China so the
people who are leaving China and coming
to Ecuador and then or or El Salvador
and then coming into the United States
across the southern border the Chinese
Communist Party knows about it and and
there are probably I mean we have to
consider this this is what Russia did
when it invaded Ukraine now I'm not
suggesting that China is trying to
invade the United States that's absurd
but if we're going to defend Taiwan a
divisions worth of people here observing
our military installations observing our
rail head movements of military forces
to to to help defend Taiwan potentially
sabotaging those you know rail heads and
things like that where we upload
military supplies I mean that that has
to be considered yet mayorcas doesn't
seem to care so hold on Russia did this
with Ukraine and and you're saying you
think that ji jingping is directing some
of these people to come to America to
later become sabator just explain that
for us yeah I don't have the uh
intelligence to suggest that that's a
definite plan but you you have to
consider it as a potential course of
action when Russia invaded Ukraine for
years before they sent people into
Ukraine we called them the little green
men and they went in they set up a
residence they lived there and they
became the sabots when Putin actually
pulled the trigger and invaded that very
much could be the potential here I mean
why go from 1,800 in a year to
24,000 okay we will leave it there we
you said a minute ago you're going to
have hearings on impeachment and you're
going to bring an impeachment uh in
January we're going to be watching that
Mr chairman thank you thank you have a
good day house house Homeland Security
committee chairman Congressman Mark
green thank you sir I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian killme and I'm Angley airheart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis